to present the award for costume design
is a leading lady of ghosts st. Elmo's
fire and the upcoming a few good men
with Jack Nicholson and Tom Cruise if
you saw the Vanity Fair cover who better
to give out the costume design award
then Demi Moore
it takes a great leap of faith for
someone to look at a series of drawings
and believe these sketches will evolve
into brilliant historically accurate
costumes that bring credibility to the
characters and a sense of time in place
five costume designers who have made
believers out of producers directors and
movie goers have been honored with this
year's Oscar nominations the offbeat
Adams family dressed in Gothic
tongue-in-cheek style by Ruth Meyers in
Barton Fink the look of Hollywood in the
30s as seen through the eye of the
needle of Richard hornik Bugsy's
gangster garb and Vegas glitz combined
the slick dressings of Albert Wall
Street Pirates fixies and assorted
children of all ages parade in the garb
of hooks designer Anthony Powell and the
elegance of period Franz has translated
intact to the modern screen and Madame
Bovary by the artistry of Corinne Jory
and the Oscar goes to
Albert Walski / Bugsy
thank you very much my deep I would be
greatly remiss if I didn't if I did not
mention the wonderful contribution of my
staff headed by George little and Colin
Passman by my assistants cynthia
hamilton by my by Mary Ann fields
Dominic Girardi Romano who headed a
brilliant group of craftsmen and workers
who made all the costumes and by a
wonderful hair and makeup department my
great thanks to my actors to my director
Barry Levinson to our producers Marc
Johnson by Levinson again and Warren
Beatty who created elegant and
impeccable taste and climate for us and
my deepest deepest gratitude to a loving
and supporting family and friends thank
you very much